there's a saying here
the Egyptians right the Lebanese publish
and the Iraqis read they're doing just
that in Tahrir Square the epicenter of
the protests in Baghdad Iraqis are
stopping by a library opened last month
it's in an abandoned building that has
become a landmark during weeks of
anti-government demonstrations there are
people who didn't finish their studies
or they have a low educational level
this will motivate them when they see
people reading here there are educated
people encouraging them to succeed and
return to school this library is a gift
to protesters it's operated by the
well-known Al Motta
Institute which publishes a daily
newspaper thousands of books and Arabic
and English ranging in topics from
cinema to science have been donated
Hassan Yousef is an injured veteran of
the iran-iraq war in the 1980s he says
it's clear someone doesn't like this
library in the building nicknamed the
Turkish restaurant which used to be on
the top floor side being attacked most
here in the Turkish restaurant is the
library it upsets our enemies and the
officials that attack the protesters
it's not all about using weapons we can
fight using knowledge and culture one of
the protesters main complaints is what
they say is the deterioration of the
educational system such as 50 students
often packed into one classroom
illiteracy is also a concern the Iraqi
Human Rights Commission says around 8
million 15 to 25 year olds can't read or
write
including a high proportion of young
women of course what happened with the
declaration of the educational system in
Iraq it's on purpose for the Iraqi
people in 2019 we have schools made from
mud it's a catastrophe news of the
library has spread more books are on the
way the Ministry of Culture is planning
to set up a tent in Tahrir Square filled
with reading material
the war veteran Hassan Yousef hopes the
government understands these young
people are creating what he calls a
revolution of culture and ideas intended
to transform Iraq
Natasha Ghanim al Jazeera Baghdad